we're here at the Australia wildlife
walkabout park
this is Kiana is that right yeah yeah
let me sing it correctly hi oh yeah
I say wasn't saying it correctly quiet
can I call you said so it's key and
cuyana so it's Karen what okay Christine
cuyana got it this is steven with this
ABI cause of last eighty yeah and it's
pretty to proof in so they - yeah
they're safe from the most dangerous
predator man so just behind us here all
out five kangaroos and kangaroos and
emus actually some of them have babies
in their pouches right now that's
actually a little baby tail sticking out
and that's the biggest hill I wouldn't
want to be rude but I thought that was a
an erection so he might even jump back
into Mom's pouch at that size no at that
size they get back into the pouch yep
you know that's a lot of Millennials
they move back in when there are like 20
to 23 would you like to pet name you
away an emu what I like - what would you
like to pet an emu you know I don't get
offer that every day
[Laughter]
hey guy let me ask you something you've
got Wallabies kangaroos emus all
together yeah is there ever any
intermingling of the species
there's no EMU Roos no behold the
dreaded Tasmanian Devil it sounds like
such a fierce animal and then you see
him it doesn't look very fierce we're
gonna put funny
America's looper sound effects on this
knowing going down I mean Ian devil a
very very dangerous animal but not the
most dangerous animal definitely not you
know the most dangerous animal is would
it be a snake that's not what I said I
said hello
no got it wrong again
[Music]
this is the Echidna it has a long
protruding nose very thin the sense I'm
getting from this animals very much like
hmm I don't want to be a bother
actually has a full pronged penis is
that for penises or one penis with four
tips that's one thing why why not she's
good for tipped penis it's a lot of work
if they're Jewish
circumcision there's just a few things
for good the wombat honker the wombats
yes before we meet him there's a few
things we need to understand about one
bats they are inclined to bite on the
back of your leg it's important that you
guys actually stand still because we
don't want to encourage him because if
you're moving your plane he's gonna bite
more you got to trust kiona and me so
what you're saying is when Tonka the
wombat attacks and starts biting me
I should remain perfectly still and let
him bite more until you two decide it's
time to intervene exactly they can
actually run up to 45 kilometres an hour
I've just been told not to move because
the wombat may bite the back of my legs
[Music]
the very sentiment the reasons they can
move so fast okay they gave us a pretty
scary speech before you came out you
look like you're looking for your
missing car keys
there he goes back to slaughter another
village the ultimate killing machine oh
it's a spider above you above your head
you're about to walk into it
the spiders dangerous but not the most
dangerous creature the most dangerous
creature is so this is Ganga Mao koala
they eat only eucalyptus leaves which
means that they don't get much energy so
they actually sleep at about 20 hours
every day yes I'm familiar with that
phenomenon can I talk to you for a
second Gumnut all you eat is eucalyptus
and see you have no energy you sleep 20
hours a day so you can't get a job and
that's what's destroying your life
here's I'm gonna ask you to do I want
you to try just try pizza that's look
like pizza I know it's just you know
kids don't be like I'm not apply
yourself work hard and stay off the
eucalyptus
yeah you make me sick
[Applause]